welcome back to cbs this morning instead
of our usual talk at the table now we're
sharing
how a group of best-selling authors has
teamed up to write a book exploring the
joy and wonder of black boyhood
black boy joy 17 stories celebrating
black boyhood
is a middle-grade anthology with a
medley of stories
poems and comics about the power and fun
of growing up as a black boy it is fun
first on cbs this morning we invited
five of the authors to come together in
a conversation
they are george m johnson a non-binary
writer activist and author of
all boys aren't blue kwami imbalya
is author of the tristan strong trilogy
jerry crafts
is author of new kid tochi o'neil bucci
is author of riot baby and jason
reynolds we know him very well around
here as the library of congress national
ambassador
for young people's literature and the
author of long way down
so they gathered at a coffee shop in
brooklyn to discuss their collaboration
and the importance of representing black
boys and joyful stories
and with a full range of emotions
why the title why black boy joy of all
the things it could have been right why
black boy joy and secondly what does it
mean
to you so black boy joy just the term
um was was coined about five or six
years ago
and it it's just become synonymous with
the almost just the relief
and being able to express oneself free
from all of
stereotypes judgment and outside framing
i think that for myself whenever i walk
into the kitchen my parents had the news
on it was always someone
like me in the street right or a mug
shot and i'm like
you know what if you're gonna tell the
story of the world tell the whole story
right
and this the joy the happiness the
celebration the love
i feel like that has been missing from a
lot of the stories when i was a kid
there was no joy in anyone that looked
like us and if there was you knew that
if they had a happy moment
they were just setting you up to you
know what i mean
so like the whole thing could be oh he's
trying to get that harvard
right at the end he'd finally get that
leather right
and he'd open it up and just then
someone would come up boom
boom boom boom and you'd see the leather
floating down
[Music]
[Laughter]
so when you ask me to be in this you had
me at the title
i'm going to be with people who aren't
writing to that story
so for me black boy joy is really
getting into the stories that have
always existed but rarely ever get told
i think about how my grandmother or
great grandmother has sayings like you
counted all joy
and what that really means is like even
the bad days there's still joy there
i often think about the movie stand by
me which was like you know these four
little white boys that got to have like
adventure
and fun and it's like i remember being a
young black boy with my two cousins who
i grew up with in my little brother and
we
were those four little boys but we never
got those stories
and so for me this was the opportunity
to
one tell the story of who i would have
been
if i had language as a non-binary kid
and
also reflect on the relationship that i
had with my grandmother that i had with
my family which was supportive of me
as a young queer boy who didn't have
language and who didn't
know what was going on with me and two
ensure that
uh there was representation of what we
think of
the black male image the black man image
and knowing that it doesn't all come
packaged in
the same thing it's liberation for me
the story that i wrote um coping is
about this this
young black skateboarder and when i was
his age
my dream was to be in the x games that
was my thing but i'd never
seen that depicted for me it's always
about like
humanity and magic
in mundanity for black people right like
i believe that black people are as
boring as everybody else
all right right
we live humdrum lives like everybody
else i think that like
if we can recognize the magic there
there's joy
the beauty of these 17 stories the joy
is the final destination
right but the root that everyone takes
is totally different
as you're writing your story how did you
navigate towards the joy the question
that i
asked myself was okay where's this kid
finding joy
and at the beginning he thinks that joy
is caught up in physical achievement
he's like i want to be able to do this
thing and get famous
and hear the crowd roar my name is i'm
at the top of this
like half pipe getting ready to do all
types of
daring stuff but the journey he goes
through ends up being that
oh there can be joy in helping others
there can be joy in making sure somebody
has something to eat
you can put a smile on another person's
face and there's some sort of alchemy at
work
that puts a smile on your face as a
result and that was something that was
very important for me to sort of dive
into and explore
because i think you know particularly
with regards to achievement and the
interaction of that with black boyhood
it's like
oh you got to do good to get out the
hood or you got to do good to
fulfill this family expectation or that
you know
like where is there space for the black
boy to figure out what he wants to do
what brings him joy right and i think in
my story that's really all i was trying
to say is like what about the kid who's
like hey
that first day of school i don't know
about y'all but when i was coming up
that first day and you had to get
dressed it was like hey you getting
ready to walk in and this is going to
set the tone
this your force field right this is
going to be it for the whole semester
right even if you were a kid who didn't
have much which is in my story he ain't
got a whole lot
he got sneakers that he's already owned
for a year and i think what i wanted to
shine light on
is that yo you got black boys who you
like growing my household you cared
about your parents
you took care of your things you
idolized your big bro
for many reasons right and that all were
negative
and to show like the care that goes into
that first day
if you talk to your grandmas and your
grandfathers they're going to tell you
keep your shoes clean
you leave this house you might not have
much it don't mean that you got to go
out
like they don't have to know that keep
your shoes clean right it was a very
real thing
because there is that kid who right now
is sitting in the back of the class
twiddling his pencils
constantly checking his jordans making
sure there's no scuffs and that kid
should be loved too i mean for me i
think the book
the book was definitely like not about
asking permission anymore it's like
about
taking up space it's a bold attempt at a
counter narrative
that we rarely get to ever explore or
that we rarely get to ever see
when you think about just even all of
last year it took
the entire world to come together to
get one white cop put in jail
um so for me this book is really about
giving our black boys uh something else
that they can hold on to in a world that
tells them that
they're not worthy of grabbing on to
anything and this will
give the green light to someone who
reads this to say you know what i didn't
necessarily feel seen in this
but i appreciate that these 17 other
types of us got seen but maybe i'll
write the story for the 18th one of us
to be seen before we go i just want to
say i got a thing about making sure
black folks especially black
men publicly tell them each other that
we love each other
and so i just want to say like i love
y'all man it's important that we
publicly do that
yeah i love that he did that at the end
i do too it's such an important
conversation to show that black people
it's not all humdrum i have to say
i thought that was funny that jason said
black people live home drum lives
yet sometimes but i i'm so touched by
this conversation it's no secret that
i'm having a favorite grandson
yes in mid-september and favorite
daughter kirby's doing her whole nursery
and she calls it black boy joy
she's getting pictures of little black
boys walking their dogs
she's having somebody painted walking
their dogs reading a book
going to the beach just normal everyday
things that give you joy
that many times are not associated with
little black children well that's what
jesus
is important that's what jason said
there's humanity and magic
exactly in mundanity there's a lesson
there's a lesson here
though for all of us who are watching i
loved when he said what brings you joy
and it's a question for all of us to ask
what brings you joy yes
what is it yes what brings you joy i saw
a quote just outside this building that
says
find what sets your soul on fire right
find what sets your soul the quest isn't
it lovely to just witness conversations
yes i love it good conversation like
that you know what gives me joy anything
with icing
want some cakes to say a special thank
you john toward please tell us who did
that piece because that's very hard to
do
my tain thank you very much welcome
viewers watching at home it's very hard
to do a piece
where there's no track where you just
have conversation that flows and makes
sense
you guys knocked it out of the park
thank you and thank you gentlemen for
that
conversation yes david you're now
my time black boy joy on sale now
beautiful cover right
i want this book